m
c'est dans l'hémicycle du palais de la
source que le conseil départemental a
accueilli ces nouveaux apprentis
soutenir l'apprentissage comme levier
d'insertion durable dans la vie
professionnelle telle est l'ambition de
la collectivité qui accueille chaque
année plusieurs dizaines de nouveaux
apprentis une formation alliant théorie
et pratique favorisant l'insertion des
jeunes sur le marché du travail
pour cela les tuteurs s'engage à
partager leur savoir faire avec ces
jeunes et à les intégrer comme des
agents à part entière donc ils étaient
intégrés comme les agents du service ici
à new services avec une organisation du
travail un petit peu différente
puisqu'il a qu'une semaine sur deux et
donc sa demande de l'anticipation et
puis a suivi un soutien un peu plus fort
puisque parce qu'il a des bases des
bases limités et donc il faut qu'ils
prennent les monts compétences un peu
que l'agent du service ou une collègue à
part entière à qui on donne des missions
bien précises des responsabilités car ce
n'est pas parce que c'est une apprentie
qu'on doit lui donner les petites tâches
à faire au contraire elle est là pour
apprendre elle est là pour assumer des
responsabilités
donc voilà on essaye de varier en fait
ces missions
pour qu'elles puissent plus tard occuper
un poste en totale autonomie
un véritable tremplin pour ces étudiants
qui se voit offrir un itinéraire
concrets pour acquérir à la fois
connaissances théoriques et aptitudes
pratiques
ce dispositif permet aux jeunes
d'obtenir leur diplôme ainsi qu'une
expérience professionnelle lorsqu'il
vient avec l'apprentissage et le contrat
en alternance c'est que ça permet
d'acquérir de l'expérience durant deux
ans
à côté d'eux d'aller à l'école donc ça
permet de mettre en pratique ce que soit
l'école et quand l'entreprise pas trop
facile avec les devoirs ça à l'école et
en entreprise allait sur les événements
mais bon voilà on est sérieux on
s'adapte au rythme et on essaie de faire
avec
je pense que la collectivité c'est là où
tout se passe c'est vraiment le coeur
d'un de cinq minutes
vous êtes tout ce qui est à la réunion
pas c'est vraiment une chance d'être ici
sans permis d'allier théorie et pratique
et d'entrer progressivement dans le
monde du travail sur les civils c'est
bien d'avoir travaillé au département et
puis je sais qu'ils ont des compétences
le conseil départemental totalise à ce
jour 629 apprentis accueillait entre
2006 et 2015 sur ce dispositif
la collectivité est donc devenue la
première à accueillir le plus grand
nombre d'apprentis